if Scalise is joining me right now he's
been very patient weight has been
already whipped we're headed to the
White House briefing that's coming up a
few minutes from now
but Steve essentially what governors are
saying is we think it's best for our
folks to stay home period and a story
what do you think of that well clearly
you're seeing each governor handle it a
little bit differently but they're all
following the direction from the CDC and
CDC guidelines have been I think what's
been driving a lot of the decisions that
governors have been making and you know
so that's where that's where those
decisions be coming from but you know in
the end it's trying to work through and
and hold things together so that
families have something to come back to
but we could be honest and I know we're
working on a big relief package to try
to ensure for both families and
businesses that they can come back I
mean we're gonna get more details of the
next round of stimulus so there were
multiple ones that have been coming up
and you know discussed I know in the
Capitol but I've heard figures now that
are topping two trillion dollars I mean
is it getting that high higher still
what do you think well it's hard to say
on the numbers because there are a lot
of pieces that have been negotiated not
agreed to but we're trying to finalize
that over the next day or two and and
clearly there there are big pieces to it
and a lot of what you're looking at too
on the on the business side is to try to
get businesses to hold their workforce
together as much as they can I mean
we've seen large layoffs already but
there are a lot of companies trying to
make a decision
you know maybe they've got a bank coming
up in the next few days and they have
that but they also want to keep as much
of their workforce as they can and you
know we're working with the banks and
trying to get some regulatory relief I
know something I've been pushing some we
did after Katrina was gave the bank's
the ability to do up to 90 days
forbearance where they pushed loans back
an extra 90 days and gave you some
breathing room when you had no cash flow
and clearly we know that's the case
right now and there are a lot of banks
by the way that would like this ability
as well without getting penalized by the
regulator so that they could work with
their local small businesses and say
look I know you have no
revenue you can hold off for three
months push your loan back for three
months and keep your business intact and
the same is being done for families with
with mortgages I'm curious what you make
of a lot of these measures because
they're meant to reassure business as
much as the Federal Reserve and it's cut
in interest rates to zero has meant to
reassure the markets but the markets is
you know congressmen have been
collapsing we had one of our worst weeks
certainly going back to the financial
crisis are you worried this financially
at least is getting out of control
well I'm very worried about how how it's
having an impact those short term and
long term and I think the biggest
uncertainty that you're seeing in the
markets is that they don't know when
that date is going to be when things do
come back I mean we are gonna come back
you know and whether it's weeks and some
people are wondering if it's gonna be
longer than that I hope it's not and I
think once we have a clear idea you know
when you listen to dr. Falchi and others
talk about that spike and you know you
don't want the hospital system
overwhelmed but you know people want to
know okay is it gonna be a few more
weeks we can plan for that and there's
some businesses that are gonna have
trouble holding on for that long but
then there are a lot more that are
saying if this is going to be months and
that would be a whole different
situation and I think you know we've all
got to recognize that hopefully we can
address it on the front end like we are
right now and then get to a point where
when it's time to come back open there's
businesses to come back open their jobs
for people to go back to and that's
that's what we've got to be focused on
this relief package all right we'll see
what happens very good hearing you I
mean a lot of the unity in this country
that goes back to the time after you
were tragically shot congressman and
survived that ordeal at United both
parties in a way that a lot of folks
that hope would last you recovered from
that but the goodwill that came of that
was a relatively short life this
goodwill seems to be hanging on for a
while we'll see if it lasts as well so
much more on that and the impact of that
with Steve Scalise